laon de l'huile c'est bientôt dans 25
ans exactement
et bien sachez que si l'inflation devait
se prolonger au taux de l'année dernière
c'est à dire 15 % le paquet de gauloises
coûterait tenez vous bien 69 francs le
timbre poste 32 francs et le steak 1226
francs le kilo hypothèse gratuite mais
intéressant de se prenant pour celui qui
veut jouer avec les statistiques
prenons l'exemple du prix du litre
d'essence
s'il continuait d'augmenter au taux de
l'année dernière c'est-à-dire 36 74%
il s'élèverait en l'an 2000 à 3989
francs c'est inimaginable
mais rassurons-nous d'abord d'après le
gouvernement
l'inflation se ralentira dès cette année
et puis si l'inflation devait se
poursuivre jusqu'en l'an 2000 au taux de
15 %
si par ailleurs le pouvoir d'achat était
maintenue comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
la ménagère verrait ses billets de
banque se multipliaient considérablement
ainsi le smig correspondant à 40 heures
de travail par semaine
c'est la vraie en l'an 2000 à 47 1822
francs par an soit environ 4000 francs
par mois
[Musique]